just love this idea that the golden
circle is actually not two-dimensional
but three-dimensional that it is
actually basically a metaphor for how a
company looks and operates that
companies or whatever it is even our
jobs are really megaphones and that at
the core of that megaphone that you know
you just have the image of the megaphone
like a message has to go in to the
megaphone right that's the why if that
comes from us where the representative
the why the mechanism is well how I'm
going to make it from soft to loud well
that's the actual megaphone and what
comes out of it the words that come out
of it that's the what right so a company
what goes into it is the inspiration the
vision the cause right it's all in there
the company itself it's making stuff its
producing stuff and what comes out the
other end is a product to consume words
to hear that's a product to consume we
consume Martin Luther King's words that
was his product and I just absolutely
love that as a metaphor and it really
helps understand the hierarchy of an
organization that when you're in front
if you're on the if you're on the front
line you're really you know what job I'm
I'm I'm right they're making producing
serving you know making the French fries
at in-and-out burger best french fries
ever best burgers ever - that's right
right there in the front and then as you
go up you know middle management is
really this this this we you have to
manage between between the both between
the inspiration coming from up on high
and getting the actual job down that's
how we gonna do this how am I gonna turn
that into that that's really what middle
management is I just love that metaphor
because it's so true and the most fun
thing is that if the golden circle is
based on biology which it is that means
there's a biological construction to a
business that there's a limbic component
that should be at the top of the
organization and a new your cortical
component that's that's down that's down
below so we have too much neocortex at
the top too much everything's done with
numbers alone and calculations it loses
the inspiration but we have to weigh
them if we if there's not enough of that
at the front line then we never produce
anything
[Music]
you